The F-35B is arguably the most advanced plane
ever made.
A jack of all trades.
A stealth fighter plane, combining and improving
on the capabilities of the F-16, AV-8B Harrier,
and B-2.
A highly maneuverable fighter plane capable
of attacking both airborne and ground based
targets.
A stealth fighter, taking the lessons learned
from Lockheed’s previous ventures into stealth,
with the F-22 raptor and F-117 Nighthawk.
A plane fitted with the most advanced sensors
and computer systems.
Sharing information almost instantly with
allies, without compromising stealth, and
presenting the information directly on a heads
up display on the pilots helmet visor.
Giving unparalleled situational awareness.
Allowing a flight of F-35s to effectively
fight as a hivemind.
Perhaps most boldly of all, the F-35B is capable
of transitioning from horizontal to vertical
flight with a push of a button, using directional
thrust and a massive vertical turbofan engine,
hidden within the plane's body.
Making it possible to land like a helicopter
on the relatively small amphibious assault
ships of the US Marines.
Fitting all these capabilities into a single
airframe is an extremely difficult task.
Designing for stealth demands careful molding
of the exterior of the plane, dictating the
design of crucial features.
Creating unavoidable trade-offs.
There are a lot of misconceptions about stealth.
The goal isn’t to make an aircraft invisible,
it will be detectable, the goal is to delay
enemy detection for as long as possible.
For bomber aircraft, it shrinks the range
of the enemy's radar stations, potentially
opening gaps in radar defenses and allowing
the aircraft to slip through undetected.
For fighter aircraft it provides a critical
advantage, detect your enemy before they detect
you.
To gain these advantages, we need to make
it harder for the radar receiver to decipher
whether the return signal is just background
noise or an enemy aircraft.
To do that we need to minimize the strength
of the return signal.
There are several mechanisms for a radar wave
to be reflected.
The most significant, and most obvious way
is through specular return, otherwise known
as regular reflection, like a mirror.
[1] Where the angle of reflection equals the
angle of incidence.
We want to avoid large flat surfaces that
could reflect straight back to the radar receiver.
Corner reflectors, where two surfaces set
at a 90 degree angle to each other, need to
be avoided at all costs.
Tailplanes, consisting of the vertical and
horizontal stabilizer, are the perfect surfaces
to create a corner reflector.
Allowing radar to bounce off both surfaces
and return right back in the direction it
came.
The best way to avoid this is to remove the
tail completely, like the B-2, but this impacts
maneuverability greatly.
Instead we can replace both the horizontal
and vertical stabilizer with a v-tail, as
seen on the F-117 Nighthawk.
The v-tail can act as both a rudder and an
elevator, and we can see how by examining
the resultant force generated when the control
surfaces are actuated to different positions.
We can actuate them in opposite directions
to generate a horizontal resultant force,
providing yaw control as a vertical rudder
would.
Or we can deflect them in the same direction
to provide pitch control, as an horizontal
elevator would.
This configuration is sometimes used for unique
looking aircraft like the Cirrus SF50, allowing
it to mount a single tiny jet engine on top
of the fuselage with its exhaust directed
straight through the v-tail.
A private jet so tiny and lightweight that
it can deploy a parachute to rescue itself
in emergencies.
Having rudder and elevator controls linked
in a single mechanism like this is not ideal.
Fighter jets like the F-35 and the F-22 need
superior control authority, and that is a
function of control surface area.
The larger the elevator the larger the pitch
control.
If a control surface is working a double role,
where rudder and elevator action is needed
at the same time, it reduces the control authority.
So, both planes also feature large elevators,
offset by a distance and angled to prevent
corner reflections.
We can see many more trade offs in design
by comparing the F-117 and F-35 in the quest
to fulfill both stealth and fighter requirements.
Both the F-117 and B-2 have their engine air
intakes mounted on the upper surface of the
plane, which prevents ground based radar from
bouncing around inside the intake and back
to the receiver, and helps reduce infrared
heat signatures.
However, for a plane expected to make high
angle of attack maneuvers in life and death
situations, this isn’t a design you would
want to include
While performing a maneuver like this the
air intake will receive lower pressure air,
which will lower performance right when performance
is needed most.
Air intakes located underneath the aircraft,
like the F-16, will cause too much radar return,
so twin intakes located on either side of
the fuselage are instead chosen.
The air intake has some clever aerodynamic
features too.
This seemingly innocuous bump plays an important
role.
This is aeronautical engineering epitomized,
every seemingly insignificant design feature
has a purpose.
Mounting engine intakes along the body of
an aircraft comes with some issues that pylon
mounted engines avoid.
As air travels along the length of the body,
air begins to form a layer of slow moving
turbulent air called a boundary layer.
If this air is allowed to enter the engine
it not only lowers performance, it can also
damage the engine.
As the turbine rotates it will pass through
the slow boundary air on one side and then
fast free stream air on the other.
This means the force on the turbine blade
changes for each and every rotation, causing
cyclical bending.
A recipe for fatigue failure.
Planes like the F-16 feature a boundary layer
diverter that separates the inlet from the
fuselage with a small gap, but this design
increases radar cross-section and increases
drag.
[2]
Later variants of the F-16 tested the DSI,
a diverterless supersonic inlet.
Essentially a large bump that creates a region
of compression that pushes the boundary layer
away from the inlet, while also scattering
incoming radar and lowering drag.
The test flight demonstrated it could meet
performance requirements, ushering its introduction
to the F-35.
The final product reduces weight by 30% and
lowers production and maintenance costs.
Moving down the plane we can see other hints
of stealth design.
Long sharp edges are the enemy of stealth.
Sharp edges cause radar waves to scatter in
all directions, radar can even travel along
the length of a surface in the form of a traveling
wave, and then scatter upon reaching the trailing
edge.
The strength of that return signal can be
reduced with a few clever techniques.
The strength of the signal will depend on
the length of the edge, so the first technique
is to reduce the edge length with serration.
You can see this technique very clearly on
the trailing edges of the B-2.
However, it’s less obvious where it’s
used for the F-35, until you start looking
at all the access hatches hidden around the
aircraft, every single unavoidable surface
gap on the aircraft has a serrated edge.
This hatch opens to reveal a telescoping ladder
to allow pilots to climb in and out of the
aircraft.
These open to reveal the landing gear.
These are the internal weapons bays, essential
for keeping the radar reflecting missiles
hidden from view, and t hese smaller hatches
are flare dispenser doors.
Flares are effective decoys for heat seeking
missiles, but they do nothing to prevent radar
guided missiles.
In the face of radar guided missile proliferation
and continued growing sophistication in the
technology, a new decoy system was developed.
This new technology is released from this
panel.
When needed this access door opens and a transmitter
begins to reel out to a safe distance behind
the plane.
It has 3 levels of countermeasures to protect
the F-35 from attack.
First it actively jams missiles while they
attempt to lock onto their target,
by emitting jamming signals which the onboard
computer computes and delivers to the emitter
through the fiber optic tow line.
If the radar manages to obtain a lock, it
then begins to attempt to break the lock.
Disrupting the tracking algorithms guiding
the missile towards its target.
Finally, if all is lost and the missile is
bearing in on the aircraft, the emitter begins
to simulate the aircraft's radar signature,
drawing the missile towards it as a decoy.
[3]
These serrated hatches hid critical components
of the F-35, but more can be done to reduce
edge scattering in these locations.
You may notice that the color around these
edges is different to the rest of the plane.
This is because the edges are treated with
a special radar scattering tape.
In the same way traveling waves scatter when
they meet an edge discontinuity, they will
scatter when traveling over a change in conductivity.
The F-35 uses this to its advantage to scatter
the waves over a longer distance, reducing
the return signal by spreading it out.
The tape has a conductivity gradient, gradually
decreasing its electrical conductivity, causing
radar waves to scatter at each interval.
Slowly decreasing the intensity of the surface
wave before it reaches the edge where it would
have released one large return if the tape
was not present.
The surface of the plane itself is composed
of specialized radar absorbing material.
In 2010 Lockheed Martin filed this patent
for a carbon nanotube infused composite material
that can absorb radar waves from 0.1 megahertz
through to the 60 gigahertz.
This is an incredibly wide range of frequencies,
notably covering the frequencies Russian surface
to air missiles like the advanced S-400 system
uses.
The effect traveling surface waves have on
stealth design can be seen elsewhere.
You would imagine a cylinder would great way
to scatter radar in all directions, lowering
the strength of the return signal, but if
a radar wave comes in tangentially to a cylinder,
and the wavelength is at least 1/10 the cylinders
circumference, the wave can actually travel
around the outside of the cylinder and travel
straight back to the receiver.
[3]
This is likely why the F-35 features this
sharp edge breaking up the circular nose cone.
Where the f-16 has a nearly perfect circular
nose cone, the F-35 features a ridge.
The largest hatch on the plane is strangely
not serrated, and this is for good reason.
This hatch hides the powerful lift fan within.
The air flow in and out of this lift fan needed
careful consideration.
The lift fan is essentially a tiny helicopter,
capable of generating 85 kN of vertical thrust,
and in doing so it creates a lower pressure
zone above the plane, violently sucking air
into the aircraft at a 90 degree angle.
This air has to travel over the hood to reach
the inlet, and thus the hood needs to allow
air to smoothly pass over it without creating
too much turbulent flow, which would lower
the performance of the lift fan.
This is why the inlet door is not serrated,
as the sharp edges would cause distortions
in the flow.
This hood alone went through several design
iterations to optimize the airflow flowing
by it.
The demonstration X-35 aircraft had two doors
opening towards the side of the aircraft,
but this was changed for the final aircraft
in favor of a rear hinged door.
This helps funnel air into the engine and
improves pressure recovery on short take-offs
where the F-35B does not take off vertically,
instead using the lift fan and directional
thrust of the rear nozzle to take off on extremely
short runways.
The way this aircraft transforms to perform
vertical landing and short takeoffs is astounding.
It’s the closest thing to a transformer
we have ever created.
When the time comes, a clutch linking the
extended driveshaft of the F-35s engine begins
to transfer 29,000 horsepower to the bevel-gear
of the lift fan..
Spinning the contra-rotating lift fan.
Simultaneously gears begin to rotate in the
rear exhaust nozzle.
The mechanics of this nozzle are another wonder
to behold.
Called the three bearing swivel nozzle.
It is composed of three airtight segments
cut at angles relative to one another.
[4] We can change the shape of the nozzle
by rotating these angled pieces separately.
These 3 pieces rotate together to smoothly
transition thrust downwards, but it’s slightly
easier to understand how it works by seeing
what happens when we rotate segments individually.
Rotating the central piece can take the nozzle
from a zero degree turn to 45 degrees.
This position is used for short take-offs
splitting the engines power between thrust
and lift.
This mode is just as impressive as vertical
take offs.
Allowing the plane to operate from shorter
amphibious assault ships like the USS Makin
Island, a ship just 258 meters long.
Its minimum take-off distance decreases even
further with the aid of a ski-jump.
A ramp that has been added to smaller amphibious
assault ships.
Watching the F-35 take off over such short
distances is incredible.
In this clip we can see the rear nozzle quickly
adjusting its angle of thrust, in sync with
the rear elevators, to adjust the pitch of
the plane to ensure a safe take-off.
For a vertical landing the final nozzle segment
can rotate to provide the full 90 degree turn.
The first nozzle segment can rotate to move
the nozzle side to side, but here it’s needed
to ensure that the thrust doesn’t move sideways
as the nozzle transitions.
As we saw when we rotate the segments individually
they move in an arc that would cause the F-35
to spin out of control.
This mechanism also allows the F-35 to smoothly
transition from cruise to vertical flight
and from vertical flight to cruise when needed.
There are additional control mechanisms to
ensure this precarious balancing act does
not go wrong.
Bleed air from the main engine bypass is siphoned
to two roll nozzles located on each wing.
Providing thrust far away from the plane's
center of pressure to control roll.
There are also guide vanes located underneath
the lift fan.
This can adjust the outlet area to adjust
the performance of the liftvan, but also control
the thrust of the lift fan from 5 degrees
forward to 42 degrees backward.
With computer assisted control of these control
mechanisms the F-35 is remarkably stable compared
to its predecessor the AV-8B Harrier.
Allowing the single engine of the F-35 to
hover on two columns of air.
To do this the F-35s engine, the F-135, developed
from the F-119 engine of the F-22 raptor,
had to be incredibly powerful.
The F-22 raptor is a twin engined fighter.
Giving it plenty of excess power to pull off
incredible maneuvers.
The F-35 only has one engine, and needs to
squeeze out all the power it can get to perform
a vertical landing.
Where the F-22’s engine can generate 156
kilonewtons of thrust, the F-35s can generate
191.
The F-35's engine has a much larger fan and
bypass ducting, giving it twice the bypass
ratio of its F-22 counterpart.
Providing the F-35 with a more efficient engine
for cruise, but also a much higher mass flow
rate for higher thrust.
However this does come with some drawbacks.
Air that travels around the engine core completely
avoids the combustion chamber, and thus misses
out on the acceleration generated here.
Reducing the exhaust velocity.
This reduces the top speed of the plane.
The max speed of the F-35 is 1.6 mach, and
while it’s the first plane capable of vertical
flight and supersonic flight, the F-22 can
fly at 2.2 mach.
The F-35 was optimized for loiter time, not
speed.
However, all that extra weight needed for
vertical take off seriously hampers that ideology.
The liftfan module weighs 1.2 tonnes, weight
that does nothing in normal flight and requires
more fuel to carry, and to make matters worse
that space is used for an internal fuel tank
for its variants.
Making the lift fan as light as possible was
pertinent to making the F-35B viable in the
battlefield.
The fact it only weighs 1.2 tonnes is astounding.
It contains two counter-rotating titanium
blisks.
Blisk meaning the blades and disk are all
one single piece, instead of the traditional
alternative of creating a disk and attaching
blades through dovetail connections.
This improves efficiency and eliminates a
potential site of failure in the connection.
This is an astounding feat of manufacturing,
and the first stage fan takes it even further.
The first stage blades are hollow to save
weight.
Where the F-35B truly comes into its own however,
is in it’s modern suite of sensors and computers,
all feeding into this.
The heads up display incorporated into the
pilots helmet.
Traditional heads up displays, like those
of the F-16, are incorporated into a panel
in the cockpit.
A panel which the pilot cannot see when scanning
their environment.
Situational awareness is everything in the
heat of combat, and this helmet does everything
it can to keep the pilot informed.
Even giving them x-ray vision and night vision.
Information from a suite of sensors around
the plane feed into a central computer, where
it is processed and displayed through a projector
inside the helmet.
Inside this transparent faceted box underneath
the aircraft is a suite of sensors.
Those are not your typical windows.
These windows are made from a notoriously
expensive gemstone, sapphire.
One of the few materials that is both hard
and durable, but also transparent to a broad
range of electromagnetic wavelengths.
From the ultraviolet to infrared.
However, the radar antenna hidden inside the
nose of the F-35 is the most important part
of this electronics system.
This is a scanned array radar that works very
differently to traditional mechanical radar.
Phased array antennas have hundreds of tiny
antennas.
We can see metal plates set in rows in the
F-35 phase array antenna.
The metal plates have slots cut into them,
and each and every one of these slots is an
antenna. 1600 in total.
This allows the phase array antenna to steer
its radar using constructive and destructive
interference.
If two antennas release two radar waves at
the exact same time, with their peaks and
troughs line up, it will result in constructive
interference, increasing the amplitude of
the radio wave.
However if the radio waves are set 180 degrees
out of phase, matching the peak to troughs
it will result in complete destructive interference,
canceling out the wave completely.
This is how noise canceling earphones work.
They listen to the background noise and then
release a canceling sound wave to create silence.
The phased array antenna uses this phenomenon
to steer the radio waves, preventing the radar
from becoming a giant beacon leading enemies
straight to it.
Traditional phase array antennas are passive.
Meaning every antenna in the array is driven
by a single transmitter and receiver.
This would mean it can only point in one direction,
and if it encountered two enemy planes flying
side by side, and they split up, the passive
phase array antenna would no longer be able
to track both of them.
However the F-35’s phase antenna is an active
phased array, meaning each and everyone of
these antennas is an individually driven transmitter
and receiver.
Meaning the F-35 can track multiple targets
at once with zero moving parts.
The nose cones hiding these antennas need
to be transparent to radar waves, and are
usually made from glass fiber composites as
a result.
This transparency causes issues for the plane's
radar return signature, as an antenna like
this will reflect signals.
This was a much bigger issue for mechanical
radar dishes that needed to point at the enemy
to keep track of them.
The phased array can point towards multiple
targets while staying in a single position,
and this is why it is pointed skywards.
To bounce incoming radar to space.
The phased array antenna also acts as the
planes communication antenna, and this is
critical to the F-35s battle doctrine.
The F-35 excels in the battlefield because
of its networking abilities.
Relaying information between it’s squadron
This is a huge amount of data to transfer
between aircraft and allies on the surface,
and requires a high data transfer speed.
However, communication comes with one glaring
problem.
It announces your presence to anyone listening.
It is vital that stealth planes can communicate
with each other securely, and the active phase
array antenna facilitates this.
The F-35 uses the latest data link system
called MADL, improving on the experiences
learned with the F-22.
Allowing the F-35 to quickly share data securely
from individual F-35s and ground based systems.
This information is then sorted and presented
to the pilot in their heads up display right
in front of their eyes.
Giving them unparalleled situational awareness.
No need to communicate with their wingmates
if there is an adversary underneath them,
the planes communicate and feed that data
right into the helmet allowing the pilot to
look underneath the plane and see the location
of the adversary themselves.
This is the true strength of the F-35B.
It is a networked hivemind stealth fighter
capable of taking off from a ship a fraction
of the size of an aircraft carrier, and returning
while hovering in the sky like a helicopter.
It’s one of the most remarkable pieces of
military technology ever created.
The F-35 has borrowed many lessons learned
from planes like the F-117 Nighthawk and B-2,
planes that we have not made documentaries
about yet, but our friends over at Mustard
have, their B-2 documentary is 20 minutes
of beautifully crafted story filled with stylish
3D renders.
If you liked this video, you will definitely
love these Originals
You can get access to them by signing up with
the Real Engineering link in the description.
You can sign up directly to Nebula for just
4 dollars a month or 40 dollars a year.
An incredibly good price to help us build
the best creator owned streaming platform
in the world.
Or, you can use the incredible cost saving
h ack of signing up to the Nebula and CuriosityStream
bundle and get both streaming services for
just 14.79 a year.
Getting access to all of CuriosityStreams
award winning documentaries and Nebula's amazing
and ever growing catalog.
Nebula is a game changing platform.
We gathered all our favorite YouTube creators
in one place to give us the power of a collective.
Funding our best ideas for documentaries like
our Battle of Britain and Logistics of D-Day
series, Real Sciences Becoming Human Series,
we even funded Patrick Willems feature length
film that I feature in in a scene alongside
Darren Arrenosky.
That would not be possible on YouTube.
We also upload early and ad free on Nebula,
giving you early access to Sam from Wendover
and I’s antics on Jet Lag the game.
Along with exclusive behind the scenes videos
like the Layover Aftershow, and our extended
interview with David Kirtley from Helion.
We have many more documentary shoots planned
for this year, with fascinating companies
and we will be releasing behind the scenes
footage for them all.
You get all this, while helping us build a
platform that unlocks our creativity from
the shackles of an algorithm driven platform.
Signing up with the link in the description
is the best way to support this channel, while
getting some amazing entertainment and education
in return.